[Musique]
comme chaque année à pareille époque
saint tropez a pris sa vitesse de
croisière
et tandis qu'il se prépare les
vernissages de l'automne la cohorte
discipline et des tropéziens conscient
et organisé se pressent deux fois par
jour vers les hauts lieux de pèlerinage
tradition c'est sur la plage que
sévissent les non conformiste celle du
moins qui osent braver les foudres de
l'article 300 ans entre deux patrouilles
les monokini sts fonde une apparition
discrète mais vite remarqué dans leur
sillage ses gracieuses naïade draine une
faune masqué dont la nage et adapté à
l'étude du comportement des reliefs
immergé en milieu à megève
[Musique]
tout corps plongé dans l'eau suscitant
de base en haut un intérêt inversement
proportionnelle à l'importance du
maillot la neige sur le dos revient à
l'honneur mais christine caron n'y est
pour rien
[Musique]
je